porter mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs nous poursuivons nos travaux
avec l'audition de messieurs thomas
mondon et karim tadjeddine tout de
directeur associé du cabinet de conseil
mckinsey
notre commission denquête a entrepris
d'évaluer l'ampleur du recours par les
personnes publiques à des prestations de
conseil et d'en comprendre les ressorts
ainsi que les modalités le cabinet
mckinsey est un partenaire actif de
l'état et de sa transformation depuis je
crois utile de le rappeler bien plus
longtemps que la survenue de la crise en
tête nous avons reçu hier soir messieurs
votre réponse écrite aux demandes de la
commission d' enquête et nous on nous
vous en remercions je constate cependant
qu'elle est incomplète sur au moins deux
points d'une part votre contribution par
sur l'activité de mckinsey depuis trois
ans alors que la commission denquête
vous demander des informations sur dix
ans d'autre part elle ne comprend pas
les prestations réalisées pour les
entreprises publiques pour rappel sur ce
point que seul le secret de la défense
nationale des affaires étrangères et de
la sécurité intérieure ou extérieure de
l'état sont opposables aux commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires je tiens à
votre disposition besoin l'article 6 de
l'ordonance du 17 novembre 1958 qui
constitue la pierre angulaire du
contrôle parlementaire
j'invite donc mckinsey à la transparence
comme les autres cabinets de conseil je
sais pouvoir compter sur votre diligence
messieurs pour compléter les éléments
manquants de votre réponse écrite cette
audition est ouverte au public et à la
presse elle est transmise en direct sur
le site internet du sénat en raison du
contexte sanitaire les collègues peuvent
également intervenir par visioconférence
comme pour toutes les personnes
auditionnées je rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant une autre commission
denquête est passible de sanctions
pénales qui peuvent aller selon les
circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45 à 100 millions
d'âmes en jeu vous invite messieurs
londons et tadjeddine a prêté
successivement serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et dit je le jure
je jure je le jure merci monsieur
je vous laisse maintenant la parole pour
une intervention liminaire d'environ 15
minutes puis surviendront les questions
dames la rapporteure et celle de nos
collègues je vous invite à essayer de
respecter
globalement cette période de 15 minutes
justement pour que les uns et les autres
puissent poser l'ensemble des questions
dans le temps qui nous est imparti merci
et je vous laisse là temps
mais j'ai le président madame la
rapporteure mesdames mais les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs membres de la
commission d' enquête sur les cabinets
de conseil vous nous avez posé un
certain nombre de questions auxquelles
nous allons tâcher de répondre
aujourd'hui en vous apportant des
éclairages sur le rôle que peut jouer
les cabinets de conseil auprès du
secteur public je suis responsable du
pôle secteur public de maquiller france
est thomas london à mes côtés
responsable du pôle santé publique nous
pourrons répondre aux questions qui
concernent notre action dans notre champ
de responsabilité il se peut qu'il est
question de plus global qui dépasse
notre champ et le cas échéant nous
reviendrons vers vous après par écrit
j'organiserai ce propos introductif
autour de quatre volets en réponse au
questionnaire transmis une brève
description de notre cabinet une
présentation du périmètre de nos
activités nos règles déontologiques et
d'engagement et enfin deux premières
réponses aux questions spécifiques que
vous nous avez posé notamment sur la
question des propos nous de la
protection des données ou du
développement des compétences
j'essaierai dans ses propos introductifs
d'expliciter les principes sans entrer
le détail des projets réalisés nous
serons heureux d'illustrer ces principes
plus tard à travers des exemples
concrets
notre cabinet maclean's et existe depuis
presque un siècle il a été créé depuis
1926 et depuis cette date accompagne à
la fois les organisations privées
publiques et associatives dans la durée
notre engagement auprès de ses lecteurs
ce soit économique en france et
également ancien mckinsey a été établie
en france en 1964 et compte aujourd'hui
environ 600 professionnels répartis dans
les bureaux à paris et à lyon le cabinet
on pressent salariés en contrat de
travail de droit français est
immatriculé pro registre de société et
respecte l'ensemble des règles fiscales
et sociales françaises applicables aux
sociétés
c'est d'ailleurs un préalable pour
répondre aux appels d'offres publics la
présence de matinée auprès des
administrations publiques en france est
très ancienne vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président nous avons
notamment en 1947 accompagner la
direction du trésor dans la mise en
oeuvre du plan marshall c'est un
engagement de longue date et nous
accompagnons régulièrement les acteurs
du secteur public en france depuis
désormais plus de 15 ans parmi les
clients vous nous avez posé la question
nous accompagnons au sein de maclean's
et france à 84% des y ait des clients
français
pour réaliser nos missions nous sommes
organisés autour de pôles de compétences
sectorielles
nous avons ainsi un impôt le secteur
public que je dirige qui est en charge
de coordonner dans la durée nos appuis
auprès des responsables opérationnels
public ce pôle représente environ à peu
près 5 % de notre activité en france
pour pouvoir exercer nos missions le
pôle secteur public lorsque c'est
pertinent mobilise descendent expertise
fonctionnelle métier typiquement par
exemple de domaine des opérations des
organisations où nous avons des
spécialistes et qui viennent renforcer
en fonction de thématiques particulières
du projet nous pouvons aussi nous
appuyer sur deux centres de recherche
propriétaire nous investissons chaque
année environ 10% de nos ressources dans
de la recherche primaire au sein des
équipes de recherche dédié comme le
mckinsey global institute par exemple
sur les centres sur les économies
sectorielles ou laissant de mobilité
demain et enfin nous pouvons également
nous appuyer sur un réseau de presque 35
mille pour la borat heures dans 67 pays
qui nous permet de mobiliser de manière
extrêmement rapide et précise les
meilleures expertises mondial de points
importants nous ne considérons bien sûr
pas que le secteur public fonctionne
comme une entreprise privée nous ne
considérons pas non plus que les
enseignements d'autres pays puissent
être répliqué au contexte français c'est
le rôle de ce pôle secteur public de
s'assurer que l'ensemble de ces
informations
d'autres métiers d'autres secteurs son
contexte réaliser est utile pour les
décideurs publics
s'agissant de notre périmètre d'action
également quelques précisions dans notre
métier de conseil et d'accompagner de
manière temporaire et ainsi se massent
sur ce mot temporaire des responsables
opérationnels pour les aider à accomplir
leurs missions et renforcer et
développer les compétences de leur
équipe nous ne ferons pas de missions
d'externalisation ou doubt sourcing
c'est à dire des délégations durable de
mission ça peut être le cas à part dans
les systèmes d'information ou la veille
ce n'est pas notre métier nous ne
faisons pas non plus de missions de
certification ou d'audits externes
c'est-à-dire la publication d'un rapport
indépendant qui analyse la conférence it
et par rapport à un référentiel
nous ne conduisons pas non plus nous ne
faisons pas de conseils de nature
juridique ce n'est pas notre métier et
nous conduisons pas d'activités de
lobbying de communication notre métier
nous intervenons essentiellement dans
deux cas de figure en amont de la prise
de décisions pour aider un sourire celle
ci grâce à des travaux d analyse
factuelle et en aval de la décision pour
aider les responsables publics dans
l'exécution
je voudrais maintenant revenir sur une
question qui a été débattue dans les
sessions précédentes c'est pourquoi les
responsables personnels publics font ils
appellent à des cabinets de conseil quel
est notre valeur ajoutée
déjà un point préalable reprend un
cabinet de conseil ne traduit ni un
défaut de compétence ni une faiblesse
d'un responsable d'une organisation
le report au cabinet-conseil quand on
regarde dans l'ensemble des économies
matures s'est beaucoup développée au
cours des dernières décennies le
président du syntec manjoo courtecuisse
indiqué les chiffres en france ce marché
du conseil à doubler en plus de 10 en
moins de dix ans pourquoi pour trois
raisons d'une part les responsables tant
publics que privés sont soumis à des
enjeux de plus en plus complexe qui
requiert des champs d'expertisé de plus
en plus large typiquement un responsable
à pouvoir appréhender les enjeux
technologiques opérationnel d'expérience
clients le niveau de spécialisation ne
cesse également de croître il n'est pas
toujours possible ou justifier
d'internaliser ces expertises
typiquement certaine expertise
utiliser ponctuellement ou de manière
pas suffisantes pour justifier une
internalisation nous pouvons mettre à
disposition de nos clients quasi
immédiatement les exercices les plus
pointues et les plus récentes d'autre
part les responsables seront soumis à
des évolutions très importante de
charges par exemple instruire au
réaliser un projet venez essayer de
mobiliser des équipes de plusieurs
dizaines de collaborateurs pendant
quelques semaines ou quelques mois
réponse à une crise sûr que nous y
reviendrons mais c'est de pouvoir
mobiliser du jour au lendemain les
équipes également large et
pluridisciplinaire nous avons la
capacité quasiment du jour au lendemain
de pouvoir mobiliser ces renforts au
service des responsables publics
troisième raison le besoin permanent
d'innovation le métabolisme le rythme
d'innovation notamment technologiques
s'est beaucoup accéléré dans ce contexte
il est important pour les responsables
opérationnels d'être à l'écouté des
évolutions technologiques managériale
opérationnel nous avons par notre réseau
international et à travers l'ensemble
des secteurs une capacité à filtrer et
apporter les aînés de nouvelles
contextualiser aux besoins propres des
responsables du secteur public c'est
sept triples évolution recherche d'
expertise volatilité de l'activité
besoin d'innovation qui explique la
progression forte des métiers du conseil
au cours des dernières décennies et qui
va probablement se poursuivre dans les
prochaines années
s'agissant spécifiquement du conseil au
secteur public s'agit maintenant d'une
pratique courante dans l'ensemble des
pays développés notamment en europe en
allemagne au royaume-uni dans les pays
scandinaves la france a suivi le même
mouvement avec une moindre ampleur le
recours aux conseils externes depuis
plus de 15 ans cette pratique est
devenue normés et usuelle en france
l'état s'est dotée de véhicules de
contractualisation normés
et a mis en place des procédures de mise
en concurrence avec une édification de
marché à l'offre économiquement la plus
avantageuse
le marché est aujourd'hui structuré et
ouvert et a fait appel sur une base
régulière à plus de 25 acteurs
différents de conseil et aussi à des
plus petites structures ce qui permet
aux responsables publics d'avoir accès à
un large champ de compétences et des
expertises spécifiques adaptés aux
besoins de chaque mission
l'état a également construit des
centrales d'achat de conseil que ce soit
la dtp que vous avez auditionné la 10e
dans le domaine des achats l'adie num
dans le domaine numérique l'ugap
ainsi que des équipes au niveau des
secrétariats généraux des ministères
avec des équipes expérimentées à la fois
dans notre expérience de praticiens
l'application amont des besoins et le
pilotage opérationnel et conduit selon
de très bons standards
il reste bien sûr des marges
d'amélioration et de réflexion j'y
reviendrai plus tard monsieur le
président madame la rapporteure dans mon
monde dans mon propos liminaire je
voudrais à présent détailler rapidement
les règles éthiques et d'engagement que
nous mettons en place d'un secteur
public
la déontologie est vraiment au coeur de
notre relation avec un client
pareillement matthieu courtecuisse je
l'avais rappelé à tout moment un
décideur policiers d'arrêter un projet
et de la relation de confiance qu'on
peut avoir le cul est essentielle dans
notre capacité à l'accompagner dans la
durée nous avons codifié l'ensemble de
nos engagements dans un code de conduite
qui est en ligne et que nous avons
transmis à vos services
nous avons également défini des règles
d'intervention spécifique pour
intervenir dans le secteur public nous
intervenons uniquement en accompagnement
des responsables publics exécutif ce qui
exclut de fait les acteurs législatif
des organes de contrôle ou d'évaluation
de l'action publique nous ne servons pas
non plus les partis ou les personnalités
politiques c'est interdit dans nos
statuts
mcinnis êtes ainsi en mesure de
conserver toute la neutralité de la
dépendance requises pour le bon d'un
conflit dans l accomplissement de ses
missions nous intervenons à travers des
contrats cadres obtenus dans le cadre de
processus compétitif nous sommes
intervenus essentiellement au cours des
dernières années au au travers des
contrats cas détruit auprès de la dtp et
de l'ugap nous disposons également
d'autres contrats cadres avec d'autres
administrations notamment la dde la dge
nous intervenons dans le cadre de
groupements dans lequel nous
sélectionnons des sous traitants
notamment des pme françaises pour
construire un écosystème cohérent et
permettre aux donneurs d'ordre acceptant
une offre large et diversifiée nous
l'avait demandé nous pratiquons des prix
publics inférieurs de l'ordre de 15 à
30% par rapport au prix moyen pratiqué
dans secteur privé dans ce cadre
maquilleuse et intervient en amont de la
décision publique en apportant une base
factuelle et des outils d analyse ou
dead à la décision ou en aval de la
décision pour accompagner la mise en
oeuvre des orientations retenues elles
soutien au développement opérationnel
toujours en étroite collaboration avec
les publics concernés
les sujets sur lesquels nous intervenons
concerne plus particulièrement deux
sujets l'amélioration de la qualité de
service aux citoyens notamment la
réduction du délai de traitement des
demandes ou la facilitation de l'accès
aux services publics à travers la
digitalisation où le réseau et
l'amélioration de l'efficacité de
l'action publique notamment au travers
du renforcement des processus d'achat ou
encore de l'amélioration des processus
opérationnels
par exemple les parcours client dans le
secteur hospitalier
afin de répondre à ses appels d'offres
ou à des projets maclean's et nous
assurons systématiquement que les
travaux pourront remplir trois
conditions
atteindre un impact tangible et
mesurables nous pouvons nous voulons
tout moment pouvoir expliquer voilà ce
qu'on a coûté voilà quel était l'impact
collectif de notre engagement à apporter
une expertise sectorielle ou
fonctionnels spécifiques complémentaires
à celles des clients et accompagner le
développement des compétences des
organisations publiques la
complémentarité d'un principe d'action
majeure pour nous l'apport se fait
toujours en appui des structures
publiques jamais en substitution et tout
au long des projets un accent
particulier est mis sur l'implication
des agents publics en général et le
format le plus efficace de constituer
des équipes mixtes mêlant des membres de
l'organisation cliente et des membres de
cabinets permettant d'assurer
l'appropriation complète des outils
méthodologies mise en place les règles
je viens d'écrire sont vérifiées avant
le début de chaque projet par une équipe
risque basés au niveau européen est
indépendante de nos pôles pour s'assurer
que ces principes sont bien vérifier
avant le démarrage de tout projet
enfin je souhaiterais revenir sur cinq
points qui ont fait l'objet de questions
ont été débattues lors des précédentes
auditions
s'agissant des pro bono je le rappelle
ce sont des projets à titre gracieux
effectué selon les mêmes standards que
les autres projets ces missions sont
rares et concernent des sujets
spécifiques et sont entièrement décoré
les de notre activité client classique
pourquoi faisons nous des projets bono
pro bono la question du sens et notre
impact social est essentiel c'est un
facteur massif pour nous à la fois de la
traction de rétention développement de
personnes
alors nos stratégies pro bono et des
finales à l'échelle globale et vise à
contribuer à des thèmes d'intérêt
sociétaux essentiellement auprès de
structures associatives typiquement pour
donner des exemples nous sommes
intervenus récemment au bénéfice de
du secteur culturel totalement pour
accompagner des musées dans des
stratégies de radiation n'ont fait pour
le louvre pour le centre pompidou pour
des projets collectifs nous avons par
exemple accompagné la préparation du
dossier de candidature de la france où
julio pour 2024
ou des travaux également de coordination
ou de recherche c'est par exemple ce que
l'on fait pour le take for good en fait
nous aidons à coordonner les groupes de
travail constitués de 80 entreprises
organisations pour prendre des
engagements sociétaux
en faveur de l'utilisation de la tech
notamment pour la diversité et
l'inclusion au cours de ces dernières
années nous avons pratiquement fait
évoluer notre nos règles en matière de
pro bono nous avons notamment mis en
place désormais impossible systématique
de contractualisation intégrant des
clauses qui précise que nous ne pouvons
bénéficier d'aucun traitement
préférentiel dans les appels d'offres
futurs
nous expliquons également dans ses
contrats pourquoi nous faisons ce pro
bono
no - nous pensons qu'il sera important
de renforcer ses règles pour l'ensemble
de la profession et à ce titre les
propositions faites par le syntec
notamment sur la problématique de
mécénat de compétences nous semblent
aller dans la bonne direction
second point s'agissant de la perception
d'allers retours entre secteur public et
secteur privé
quelques chiffres sur les 600
collaborateurs de maclean's et seulement
7 ont une expérience antérieure dans le
secteur public de plus de deux ans soit
environ 1 % de nos effectifs sur ces 1 %
la moitié n'ont pas effectué de projets
dans le secteur public au sein du
cabinet
nous recrutons uniquement sur des
critères objectifs de compétences les
candidatures se font en ligne chaque
candidat doit passer entre cinq à dix
entretiens avec des études de cas une
décision d'offres est prise à
l'unanimité des intervieweurs nous
processus sont auditables entendre qu'on
peut lier nous n'avons ni la capacité de
détecter ni le droit d'exclure du
processus des personnes sur la base de
leur ascendance
après leur passage au sein de notre
cabinet certains consultants du cabinet
ont fait le choix de rejoindre le
secteur public c'est une pratique
classique qui touchent l'ensemble des
secteurs souvent lesquels les
consultants ne nous quitte après trois
ou cinq ans pour basculer sur d'autres
types d'activités parmi l'ensemble de
nos anciens collaborateurs ont fait le
recensement au 31 décembre d'environ un
pour cent d'entre eux travaillent
actuellement au sein du secteur public
troisième point s'agissant de la
rédaction des projets de loi ce n'est ni
notre all-in hautement danino de
compétences de contribuer à la rédaction
d'un projet de vote d'un texte
réglementaire nous ne le faisons pas
s'agissant de la protection de la
confidentialité des données il s'agit
d'un enjeu fondamental et vole à essuyer
dans les récentes discussions de
souveraineté de compétitivité et de
sécurité et la confidentialité et la
condition d'exercice de notre profession
a pas un seul client nous pardonneraient
de ne pas assurer la plus stricte
confidentialité par rapport à ces
données alors je reviendrai notre peau
ni ciel sur ce que vous avez appelé
monsieur le président apparente audition
le paradoxe de la donner à savoir la
réalisation de par engrenage notre
marque
j'ai dit très clairement nous
n'utilisons pas les données
confidentielles de clients pour réaliser
des benchmarks nous utilisons trois
sources de données pour ces travaux nous
donner propriétaires notamment issus des
analyses de nos centres de recherche
interne et qui sont financées sur
ressources propres c'est un axe
important de différenciation de notre
cabinet et plus largement des cannes et
de 10 de stratégie les données publiques
et s'agissant du secteur public
énormément de données sont publiées en
langue locale à notre réseau
international devant un rôle clé pour
identifier contextualiser traduire ces
éléments et les données issues
d'entretiens conduits dans le cadre de
ses travaux de benchmark le souligne que
lui dans l'objectif de ce benchmark est
toujours exposé en début d'entretien ces
règles sont explicites et formalise en
amont du travaux du vin de marque nous
précisons bien que l'ensemble de ces
travaux là seront faits sur travaux de
recherche et sur données publiques et
j'espère avoir l'opportunité de revenir
à travers des questions réponses plus
longuement sur cette question des
données qui est lui qui est importante
enfin s'agissant du transfert du
développement de compétences pour les
administrations il a été beaucoup
reproché au cabinet de conseil d'agir la
place 2 ce n'est pas notre philosophie
notre pratique notre métier de conseil
et d'accompagner de manière temporaire
des responsables opérationnels pour les
aider à accomplir leur mission et
développer leurs compétences
deux pistes de réflexion ainsi que
précédemment indiqué devient de plus en
plus critique de pouvoir déployer
pendant quelques semaines ou quelques
mois des équipes en mode projet pour
conduire des travaux spécifiques pour
répondre à des situations d'urgence
temporaire
si certaines administrations agences ont
développé cette capacité toutefois
encore face à des réalités ou des
contraintes de ressources très forte
pour pouvoir y faire face
également je redis un cabinet conseil
n'a pas vocation à effectuer de manière
durable une activité régulière si
l'administration a besoin de manière
durable et continu une expertise coeur
pour l'exercice de ses missions il
important qu'elles puissent internaliser
progressivement à titre d'exemple
s'agissant des métiers relative à
l'informatique aux digital ou donner les
administrations tendent à externaliser
plus d'activité que ce qu'on observe
dans un secteur privé je pense que ces
deux axes que je viens de décrire on
était bien la notion de la fortement
conscience en a vu deux 2 progrès très
significatifs au cours des dernières
années notamment sur le volet numérique
avec l'accélération du plan de
recrutement initié par la dîme néanmoins
nous semble qui a encore une marge de
progression est de mise à l'échelle
importante sur ces deux dimensions
j'espère que ces quelques éléments vous
ont permis de mieux appréhender la
manière dont les cabinets de conseils
peuvent être utiles aux acteurs publics
à la collectivité nous serons heureux de
vous le démontrer concrètement à travers
des exemples
au cours de la session de
questions/réponses monsieur le président
merci ce délit ne nous sommes nous aussi
très soucieux d'aborder ces questions de
façon concrète à travers des situations
sur lesquelles nous allons maintenant
vous interroger ces modems le rapporteur
qui commence
je remercie monsieur tailler in pour vos
propos liminaire en fait j'ai une salve
de cause de questions mais je vais
commencer par le début je pense que nos
collègues aussi ont des questions
à poser je voudrais savoir quelles sont
les différentes entités qui composent
mackinsey en france
et parmi elles le rôle de seth qui est
domicilié dans l'état du delaware aux
états unis donc une réponse précise à
une question précise
auprès de quelle identité en france ou
ailleurs sont domiciliés les contrats de
travail et de vos collaborateurs
travaillant en france votre chiffre
d'affaires et vos bénéfices réalisés en
france et dernière question pour cette
première salve qu'elle est l'entité de
mckinsey qui porte le chiffre d'affaires
réalisé en secteur public en france et
pourquoi le mckinsey & company france
donc ne publie pas ses comptes annuels
merci pour vos réponses
sauf s'il ya une autre album non
madame madame les reportages et répondre
à vos questions je rappelle que
l'interdît en tant que responsable du
pôle secteur public n'est pas en tant
que directeur général de mckinsey france
je le précise ce pont
jeu donc nous travail maclean's et
france est enregistrée auprès de
résistants du registre des sociétés
l'ensemble des contrats de travail est
porté par cette société de droit
français et l'ensemble deux chiffres du
chiffre d'affaires est porté par cette
société doha français l'élément que vous
mentionnez c'est que nous sommes
organisés en forme de succursales voilà
rapportant à l'entité mère qui est basé
au de l'ovaire mais l'ensemble de nos
activités secteur public secteur privé
et l'ensemble des contrats de travail
sont portés par cette société de droit
français
ce que ça signifie que vous êtes soumis
aux impôts français comme là pour bien
sûr s'il était bien sûr monsieur le
président merci
et je le dis très nettement nous payons
l'impôt sur les sociétés en france et
l'ensemble des salariés qui travaillent
dans une cité droit français qui paie
ses impôts en france
contre 3 de travail sont en france mais
sa portée par cette société de référence
et
g
avant de passer la parole à une question
plus précise mais je vous avoue que j'en
ai beaucoup d'autres
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que votre
valeur ajoutée c'est de réaliser des
expertises sur des enjeux complexes ce
que vous nous avez guide dans vos propos
alors bon je sais bien que le métier
d'enseignant est un métier très
difficile notamment
dans ce moment de crise épidémique avec
la copie de 19
mais je pense justement que se sont ils
ont démontré que c'était des experts on
may 15 matière d'enseignement or vous
avez obtenu un contrat d'un montant de
496 1800 euros
pour je cite
évaluer les évolutions du métier
d'enseignant d'enseignants vous pouvez
nous dire à quoi aboutit cette mission
oui parce que même la rapporteure c'est
un nous avons été sollicités dans le
cadre du contrat cadre de la dtp par le
ministère de le parlement serbe de l'est
du ministère de l'éducation et par la
dtp et notre rôle a été d'accompagner la
dtp pour organiser un séminaire qui
était prévu par le ministère ont un lien
avec son organisation internationale
pour réfléchir à quelles étaient les
grandes tendances d'évolution de marché
des évolutions du secteur de
l'enseignement que les études les
évolutions si attendu de marché
d'enseignants et à ce titre qu'elle
pouvait être les réflexions autour du
métier d'enseignant nous avons
accompagné la dtp dans cette réflexion
et nous travaillons maintenant madame la
rapporteure depuis une vingtaine
d'années aussi sur l'analyse de
l'évolution des systèmes d'éducation
je trouve que cette réponse est un peu
imprécise quand même de ce que c'est un
sujet
qui pourrait être un sujet d'ampleur et
le contrat il n'est quand même pas enfin
c'était une somme assez conséquente
quand même donc ça aboutit à quoi
précisément
blessé a conduit madame la rapporteure
l'ensemble de travaux qui ont été
réalisés avec à la fois la dtp une série
de questions dont qu'il s'agissait d'une
part de travaux de benchmarking de
comparaison de plaisance avaient été les
évolutions faites à un somme de pays
européens pour anticiper les évolutions
du métier d'enseignant bien analysé
également quels étaient les évolutions
des systèmes éducatifs forcément de
pilotage du système éducatif dans
l'ensemble des pignons européen et donc
réfléchir à un certain nombre de thèmes
de réflexion qui était prévue pour la
tenue d'un séminaire avec les les
responsables enseignants qui était prévu
en février 2021 madame donc il y avait
des responsables
des enseignants
s'ils collaboraient oui madame la
rapporteure mais je n'ai pas directement
piloté ces travaux le pilote l'ensemble
du secteur et j'ai des collègues qui
sont spécialistes de ces problématiques
dévolu sur l'enseignement mesdames la
reporte d'accord merci
à bien je me nathalie goulet souhaite
vous interroger oui monsieur le
président madame la reporter aux
messieurs merci de vos explications vous
avez indiqué que vous ne participiez pas
des campagnes politiques
en revanche la presse monsieur kenny
tadjeddine c'est s'est longuement
penché sur votre rôle pendant la
campagne
électorale du président macro notamment
et donc la presse évoque le fait que
vous avez comparé les prestataires
possible pour le développement d'un site
internet de campagne
avez vous effectué donc des missions
dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle et quel est votre rôle
est dans le think tank en temps réel
dont vous êtes membre du conseil
d'administration
plus généralement
une vingtaine de toujours dans la même
dans la même veine une vingtaine de
salariés
de votre société aurait participé donc à
7 cette campagne comment avez vous
assurez les règles liées aux conflits
d'intérêts et est ce que ses prestations
au figuré sur les comptes de campagne je
rappelle que 1,2 de vos
salariés et a été très rapidement
directeur de cabinet du ministre
mahjoubi donc apparemment il ya quand
même des liens assez assez fort entre
votre votre cabinet et la campagne
présidentielle merci
madame la sénatrice jeu répondra en
trois temps déjà je le répète c'est vrai
que nos statuts nous interdisent de
travailler ce soit à titre clients ou en
pro bono pour des organisations
politiques ou des hommes politiques pour
nous ne le faisons pas nous l'avons
jamais fait nous ne ferons jamais
ensuite comme vous le savez la loi
française est extrêmement protectrice
des libertés individuelles de chacun à
pouvoir participer à des activités
politiques associatives ou collectif et
donc moi en tant qu'employeur je ne suis
pas habilité ne serait-ce qu'à demander
à une personne et elle exerce des
activités ou une implication politique
donc à ce titre je suis pas en état mois
de pouvoir les mêmes serait ce pouvoir
donner des instructions dans un sens ou
dans l'autre par rapport une activité
politique et relève du registre
individuel puisque la question mais
aussi posé titre individuel depuis ma
vie d'étudiant j'ai toujours considéré
qu à côté de mon activité
professionnelle je souhaite avoir des
activités associatives au profit du
collectif donc j'ai participé à travers
ma vie effectivement à des associations
notamment temps réel que vous mentionnez
et j'ai pu avoir aussi des activités à
titre strictement personnel de nature
politique
nous nous entendons bien je crois cette
liberté fondamentale de chacun de
s'engager à côté de ses activités
professionnelles
cependant il faut que ces choses là
puissent être contrôlés évidemment donc
votre réponse suppose-t-elle que vous
avez les moyens du contrôle de
l'implication horaires de vos salariés
pour garantir que côte ils sont sur le
type d'activité donc paré madame la
sénatrice voulaient ils ne sont pas dans
le cadre de leurs occupations
professionnelles
oui bien sûr monsieur le président est à
préciser la condition de cette liberté
individuelle et bien sûr de ne
l'utiliser en aucune manière les
ressources collectives de notre
institution et que l'engagement soit
fait en dehors du cadre professionnel et
tient aussi à souligner on doit et
respectent strictement les obligations
de confidentialité
à l'égard des projets qui peuvent être
conclus comment l'avez vous avez raison
monsieur près comment est-ce que vous
contrôlez contre concrètement la bonne
application de ce principe tout à fait
sain par ailleurs nous pouvons contrôler
l'usagé des moyens pour lutter mis à
disposition par maclean's et à
l'intention de ses salariés
bien est-ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
à mme goulet sur le sujet
ah non pour tout simplement préciser
puisque monsieur mahjoubi n'est plus
ministre est-ce que celui de votre
enfant votre salarié qui était devenu
son directeur de cabinet est il revenu
dans votre société alors madame a
service je pense que la personne à
laquelle nous ferons ce n'était pas
directeur de cabinet
à vérifier ce point ensuite je le redis
nous moins d'un pour cent de nos
effectifs sont actuellement dans le
secteur public donc ça vous donne quand
même une idée du fait que ça reste
extrêmement marginale par rapport à
l'évolution des collaborateurs et il n'y
a pas d' aller retour et je dois
également dire que en tant qu'employeur
je dénie contrôle non plus sur les choix
individuels qui sont faits les personnes
qui quittent notre cabinet adama
sénatrice si on reste sur ce sujet là
vous avez vous même monsieur tadjeddine
participer aux travaux de la commission
attali pour la libération de la
croissance française
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
quel était le véhicule juridique de
cette prestation est elle gratuite ou
pas et est ce que vous pouvez préciser
si des consultants de mckinsey en tant
que ça arrive mckinsey ont été mobilisés
ou si d'autres consultants l'ont été
mais sur leurs heures de liberté si je
puis dire
donc vous faites référence activement
aux supports que nous avons apportées
aux travaux de la commission attali ça
devait être effectivement dans les
années
2008 et une deuxième en 2010 2011 ce
support ça a été fait dans le cadre d'un
projet pro bono donc beaucoup c'est un
projet qui a été fait qui a été validé
par la direction du bureau de paris dans
lequel il ya une mobilisation de
conseils pour pouvoir accompagner les
travaux de la commission
à travers des analyses de recherche au
même titre que d'autres cabinets ont
contribué à ces travaux pensent
notamment accenture capgemini également
que vous avez auditionné il y avait
ainsi un centre de cabinet qui avait
décidé de mobiliser des équipes en
support aux travaux de la commission
monsieur le président
il y avait un contrat même dans cette
activité gratuite ou pas je l'ignorent
monsieur le président à l'époque j'étais
jeune consultant et donc je n'étais pas
amoureux d'avoir contracté à cette
époque-là
pc de ma board pour les questions
suivantes oui merci pas de questions qui
s'inscrivent exactement dans la suite de
celles qui viennent d'être posée la
première pour monsieur landon qui en
2010 cette fin un peu avant 2017 a
travaillé à d une publication de
l'institut montaigne qui se voulait un
peu plate forme programmatique en vue de
la campagne présidentielle
j'ai bien entendu la réponse de monsieur
tajeddine qui dit que vous faites ça sur
votre tant personnelles que vous ne
devez pas utiliser
l'information dont vous disposez mais
pour autant votre notice biographique
sur la page de ma king c est fait et a
quand même de votre participation
notamment à la commission alors je
voudrais pas sur l'avenir des centres
hospitaliers universitaires dont vous
aviez déjà et c'était en 2009 largement
travaillé sur le secteur de la santé
comment faites vous alors pour être
totalement nouveau quand vous arrivez
sur ce sujet et ne faire abstraction de
tout ce que vous avez pu consulter comme
masse de données avant pour les clients
publics pour lesquels vous avez
travaillé et donc est ce que vous
estimez qu'effectivement c'est à des
auditeurs ou à des conseillers du
secteur public de venir faire des
propositions pour l'évolution de la
politique publique alors même que
certaines que vous faites créé derrière
des marchés pour vous même puisque quand
vous proposer en 2010 est d'ouvrir les
données de santé comme on sait tous où
en est l état a encore plus à cette
époque là pour l'informatisation et la
numérisation on voit bien que derrière
ça donnait un débouché aux secteurs des
cabinets de conseil donc ça c'était ma
première question est ma seconde serait
si vous pouvez le faire vous nous avez
parlé de vos actions pro bono est ce que
vous êtes capable de nous dire combien
vous en avez fait dans quel secteur des
politiques publiques et pour quels
montants cumulés et est ce que certaines
de ses prestations pro bono ont débouché
par la suite sur des prestations
payantes
selon donc oui je veux merci madame la
sénatrice je vais répondre à la première
partie de la question et peut-être mon
collègue karim tadini répondra sur la
deuxième partie
donc pour ce qui est des travaux de
l'institut montaigne dont l'institut
montaigne qui est un think tank
indépendant dont sont membres de
nombreuses sociétés donc mckinsey et
membre du think tanks l'asti des assidus
montaigne et donc à ce titre nous
participons régulièrement un certain
nombre des travaux de réflexion qui sont
menées par te pares surfing est donc en
l'occurrence effectivement ce travail là
j'ai contribué à des travaux qui étaient
des travaux collectifs qui ont mobilisé
alors je serai pas vous dire les
chiffres exacts mais plusieurs dizaines
d'experts venant de tous bords qui ont
comporté un grand nombre d'auditions
voilà et donc c'est ces travaux
collectifs qui n'étaient pas des travaux
de mckinsey mais bien de l'institut
montaigne think tank indépendant auquel
auquel j'ai contribué et auquel j'ai
effectivement voilà amené à mais mon
expérience
des années d'appui aux acteurs du
secteur
deuxième one précise deuxième point de
précision par contre comme encore une
fois ça a été précédé en propos
liminaire nous nous interdisons
absolument d'utiliser des données
confidentielles que nous aurions pu
collecter au cours de nos travaux
clients pour d'autres travaux ont
d'autres clients et donc ça a été
également le cas dans ce dans ce cas de
figure là
madame la sénatrice à 10 ans votre
question sur les pro bono nous
effectuons de l'ordre de 2,3 propre
projet provost nos parents qui sont
décidés par la direction générale la
maquilleuse et françois pas des
orientations globales
nous n'avons en à ma connaissance
jamais c'est suivre en pro bono d'un
projet client pharmaciens
quand vous nous dites 2,3 par an ces
temps pour les administrations centrales
que pour désordre global d'allier tout
ce qui est public tout ce qui est public
et associatif c'est la totalité des
projets propres y compris les
entreprises publiques ah oui la
reconnaissance jamais fait de projet pro
bono pour les entreprises publie
leurs portes oui avant de venir des
questions plus précisément sur la crise
sanitaire j'ai une autre question dans
la lignée de celles que l'on a posé
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer ou
d'infirmer que maxime qui a participé
depuis 2018 à l'organisation des sommets
techniques gouttes pour l'elysée si oui
pourquoi et quel a été précisément votre
votre rôle et mckinsey si c'est oui ça
aurait été chargé de préparer les débats
et de suivre le respect des engagements
financiers des participants donc
toujours la même ligne et combien
d'événements sont concernés pour quel
montant et être que mac intel aurait
donc dans ce si la réponse est oui
consentiez à des prestations pro bono
dans ce cadre il a dû même le rapporteur
que l'indiqué dans mon propos liminaire
nous avons effectivement accompagné de
forme de pro bono l'événement textron
depuis lé 2018
notre rôle ce que vous le savez le
sommet take for good c'est environ 80
entreprises associations qui se
réunissent pour prendre des engagements
collectifs du côté du secteur privé pour
faire en sorte que les progrès de la
technologie bénéficier au plus grand
nombre donc un certain nombre de
thématiques il ya cinq thématiques ont
été identifiés pour l'engagement en
faveur de la diversité et de l'inclusion
économique et l'objectif c'est que les
participants ces différentes thématiques
prend des engagements qui sont suivis
d'année en année donc nous nous
effectuons un support pour aider à la
préparation des ateliers thématiques en
rassemblant des bases factuelles et
ensuite à mettre en place des outils
pour suivre dans la durée les
égorgements qui sont faits par les
acteurs du secteur privé cet engagement
est fait sous forme de pro bono parce
qu'on considère que ça fait partie de
notre engagement également pour essayer
de mobiliser le secteur privé sur ces
thématiques d'engagement sociétal est ce
que ça donne aussi lieu une
contractualisation quelconque ça nous
avons de la première édition ce n'était
pas contre actualisé depuis lors nos
contractualiser bien contrat qui serait
un document qui décrit les objectifs
exactement c'est de l'état c'est
l'elysée qui vous passe comment je sais
pas avec qui nous contractons je pense
je sais puisque sam d'administration
sont engagés à s'évacuer
secteur public secteur public et ce
contrat est pour moi c'est ce que j'ai
indiqué dans un nouveau liminaire c'est
important nous expliquons pourquoi nous
le faisons faux pas qui pour bien
préciser que c'est un engagement
sociétal sans aucune attente de
contrepartie quel est notre périmètre de
responsabilité mais c'est toujours en
cours le dernier sommet a été annulé
comme vous le savez contre la crise
sanitaire je sais pas quels sont les
projets concernant le l'évolution de ce
sommet parce que c'est c'est un revoir
annuellement exactement
il ya maintenant à des questions mais si
des collègues ou d'autres qu'ils ont
dans la même lignée peut-être pour
rester dans le champ
oui merci monsieur le président à cette
année dit nous avait dit tout à l'heure
que et avec ma collègue christine avare
de fonds déjà appartenu commission d'
enquête sur les allers retours entre le
public et le privé vous avez dit que
vous alliez 1% à peu près de vos
effectifs ce qui est effectivement assez
peut compter comme ceux là qui
proviendraient du secteur public sauf
que tout dépend ce qu elle l % dont il
s'agit
j'en veux pour exemple je vais vous
interrogez vous même
vous avez vous avez
co écrit je crois un ouvrage je vous ai
participé à l'écriture d'un ouvrage avec
monsieur thomas cazenave qui était
directeur interministériel la
transformation public donc celui qui
donne crédit pour faire des études à des
cabinets de conseil
vous avez je crois qu écrit un ouvrage
donc vous vous le connaissez qu'elle
règle à titre illustratif
déontologique avez vous eu puis mettre
en place dans ce cadre-là entretenir vos
écritures ou vos amitiés commune et et
des contrats qui ont pu être passés à ce
moment là
qu'elle n'a jamais été membre de nos
effectifs
donc que ça déjà pour le préciser donc
je suis pas sûr de bien comprendre la
question de dire plus précisément vous
avez co écrit un ouvrage avec lui vous
êtes prestataires de la déité paix dont
il est était le directeur
interministériel le délégué pardon
interministériel pour être précis est ce
que vous aviez mis une relation j'ai à
dire comme on dit dans d'autres endroits
une ride chine entre vos différentes
activités si vous êtes déportés comment
ça se passe
- comment je vois là c'est juste à titre
illustratif ne devriez pas une
tout à fait légitime déjà une précision
j'ai pas co écrit avec le livre le livre
avait été préparé par thomas cazenave et
il y avait une quinzaine de
contributions d'une des contributions au
même titre qu'un certain nombre d'autres
acteurs qui est engagée sur le sujet
transformation public et à l'époque du
livre puisqu'on parle 2014 quand le
livre a été constituée et fin 2007
thomas cazals n'était pas du tout en
poste à la dtp le prestigieuse ce point
vous avez ensuite du coup je n'ai aucune
relation n'est connu ni quelle que soit
avec thomas cazenave il était
responsable de la chaire de
transformation de public au sein de
sciences po et à ce titre il a contacté
un certain nombre d'acteurs pour
réfléchir à l'avenir de la fonction
publique donc je n'ai aucun intérêt
ensuite lorsque d'autres cas se sont
passées hier quand il peut y avoir une
présomption une perception de potentiels
conflits d'intérêts lorsque la règle est
que le décideur public se déporte voilà
il ne participe à la prise de décision
et je me semble que cette règle et
d'autres dans d'autres conditions et
suivis de manière assez rigoureuse du
côté de l'administration mais le
sénateur
merci je donne la parole à nicole
duranton ya d'autres collègues qui l'ont
demandé on ne les oublie pas mais
ensuite on fera un retour en madame la
rapporteur sur des questions liées à la
crise sanitaire la presse revient
d'ailleurs madame bureau oui merci
beaucoup monsieur le président donc
j'aurai une question l'affluence d'un
cabinet de conseil peut tendre à
l'hégémonie pensez vous qu'il faudrait
établir en france un système de contrôle
donc de la répartition des marchés
publics de conseil un peu comme sur le
modèle de contrôle européen de la
formation des cartels économique
je remercie
je pense qu'effectivement c'est
important qu'il y ait une pluralité
d'intervention de conseil auprès du
secteur public je pense qu'aujourd'hui
la structuration de la retenue je prends
l'exemple du contrat 4 avec les déités
paix est construit dans cette
perspective qu'il ya une rotation entre
les titulaires et une règle d'équilibré
de charge qui est opérée vous vient ce
sentiment madame la sénatrice que ça a
été mis en place et c'est vrai que quand
on regarde l'ensemble du marché
accessible aux décideurs publics ils ont
aujourd'hui la capacité à choisir dans
une vingtaine d'acteurs et me semble pas
qu'il ya deux situations fortes qu'ils
soient prises entre les les acteurs de
ce marché madame la sénatrice
voudrait prolonger un peu la question de
madame la sénatrice duranton
est-ce que
l'essentiel où la quasi-totalité je
crois vous l'avoir entendu dire tout à
l'heure de vos marchés sont dans le cas
de ces accords cadres la déité paix ou
es ce que vous avez quand même des
marchés résiduelles qui sont passés
directement par certaines
administrations quel on est à peu près
la proportion et d'autre part quand vous
êtes que attributaires vous allez nous
le confirmer dans le cadre du marché des
itp c'est une attribution aux
tourniquets c'est à dire chacun son tour
est ce que dans quelle proportion à ce
qui vous arrive d'avoir recours à la
sous traitance ou d'être sollicités à un
sous traitant dans ces marchés la
chope la quasi totalité de nos
prestations il ya passé la totalité
transit à travers les grands contrats
cadres donc les contres et 4 vous avez
le contrat qu'a de la dtp monsieur le
président le contrat qu'a de l'ugap et
aux sig également de contrats cadres qui
a été mis par la direction des achats de
l'état
nous n'avons pas à ma connaissance de
contrat maintenant direct avec ses
administrations et ses trois accords
cadres fonctionne au tourniquet alors
non le contrat qu'a dtp
fonctionne au tourniquet sur les autres
lots et les autres appels d'offres c'est
par l'eau à partir de prestations qui
peut être sollicité
sur votre deuxième question monsieur le
président sur la sous traitance nous
notre politique est de
canton répond à ces appels d'offres on
met en place des groupements
c'est-à-dire pour s'assurer qu'on est
capable de proposer au delà de nos
compétences internes un réseau de sous
traitants notamment locaux et qui sont
capables d'apporter des prestations
spécifiques
et du coup je pense que le montant des
prestations et selon les appels d'offres
sous traitance entre 5 et 10% mais c'est
une part qui reste assez faible des
volumes effectués
c'est à dire vous que vous dites c'est
que vous faites appel à la
sous-traitance louis pour à peu près 5 à
10% à mon temps exactement c'est un
relativement marginal est relativement
marginale et c'est vraiment en cas de
besoin de des expertises spécifiques on
n'est pas capable d'apporter en interne
est ce qui vous arrive al'inverse d'être
sollicité par d'autres cabinets
extrêmement rarement c'est peut-être
arriver il nous a reste marginal est
marginale au gîte la réponse est un
génie on va revenir à madame la
rapporteure pour quelques questions
autour de la crise sanitaire anses et je
reprendrai avec les questions de nos
collègues dans la série mais si vous
permettez monsieur le président je
voudrais rebondir sur la question 4
propre après monsieur monsieur bah cher
à monsieur tadié l'insee à propos de
votre participation à l ouvrage
qui ça que je crois l'état en mode start
up
avec monsieur cazenave et dites moi si
je me trompe mais je crois que vous avez
vous l'avez connu aussi lors de la
rédaction du rapport attali
je ne suis pas non je ne pense pas on ne
pensait pas d'accord donc j'en viens à
la crise sanitaire donc vous vous auriez
perçu fin malkin s'est pas vous
directement
plusieurs millions 13,5 nous dit on
pendant la crise sanitaire
essentiellement à partir de décembre
2020 pour l'organisation de la campagne
de la campagne vaccinale j'aimerais
savoir quel a été le rôle exact de votre
cabinet dans la définition et la
conduite de la politique vaccinale
quelle expertise donc de mckinsey qui
est un cabinet généraliste donc c'est
quoi son expertise sur cette question
qui est quand même très spécifique et
enfin l'intervention de mckinsey at elle
permis de rattraper les et
retardant le début de la campagne de
vaccination dans notre pays
je vais merci à madame la rapporteure je
vais me prendre prendre cette cette
question
effectivement nous avons été sollicités
fin novembre 2021 pour venir en appui du
des équipes du ministère
dans le déploiement de la campagne de
vaccination kobe de 19 et peut-être je
sais qu'il ya eu beaucoup de questions
également lors des auditions précédentes
là dessus donc si vous me permettez je
prendrai un petit peu de temps pour bien
explicité le rôle que nous avons joué et
peut-être également à travers la
illustrer un certain nombre des
principes d'intervention que mentionner
mon collègue tard inc karim tadjeddine
tout à l'heure et donc si vous voulez
bien je voudrais d'abord revenir sur le
cadre et le contexte de la mobilisation
et du coup préciser un peu les
expertises qu'on a mobilisé à ce moment
là en complément de celle du ministère
et puis ensuite j'amènerai quelques
éléments de précision sur notre
intervention ce qu'elle a compris et les
éléments qui en était
exclu
d'abord pour rappeler que sur le plan
contractuel donc cette prestation ses
prestations se sont faites dans le cadre
du marché des itp dont on a parlé
précédemment
et est donc le contexte dans lequel on
est arrivé donc à partir de début
décembre
il a fallu très rapidement
bâtir en l'espace de quelques semaines
puisque les premières injections ont
lieu à la fin du mois de décembre un
réseau de distribution de plus de 20000
points de vente
2100 de distribution en mesure de
prendre des commandes de près de 90
mille professionnels avec des enjeux
très très fort de délais et de qualité
de service
avec des produits dont la logistique
était complexe donc plusieurs circuits
de distribution plusieurs vaccins avec
pour certains des contraintes de
stockage à -80 avec des contraintes dans
les temps de transport maximum afin que
les vaccins ne se détériore pas et donc
il a fallu en l'espace de quelques
semaines
donc bâtir bâtir ce schéma-là ensuite
entre janvier et avril il a fallu en
gros chaque mois doubler le volume des
injections et donc des livraisons et des
volumes à transporter un million et demi
de doses en janvier 12 millions en avril
et même 18 millions en juin en juin
juillet il a aussi fallu que le
ministère bâtisse un système qui lui
permettent de coordonner avec des
échelles de temps extrêmement rapprochés
à peu près probablement de l'ordre de
250 mille personnes qui étaient
impliqués dans cette campagne dans cette
campagne de vaccination
et je dois dire qu'on a été très fier et
je reviendrai sur leur le rôle
spécifique qu'on a joué d'avoir eu
l'occasion de participer à la cette
campagne est d'aider à ce que les
résultats ambitieux soit atteint
aujourd'hui en un an on a fait enfin il
a été fait 125 millions d'injections là
où la campagne
annuel vaccinale contre la grippe c'est
de l'ordre d'une dizaine de millions
d'injections donc des enjeux majeurs et
une mobilisation en appui en
complémentarité des ressources qui ont
été mobilisés au sein du ministère et du
grand nombre d'acteurs qui étaient
mobilisés à l'appui de voix là de
résultats de résultats tangibles
pour cela nous nous sommes appuyés sur
un certain nombre d' expertise
en terme de logistique en terme de
campagne de vaccination et de gestion de
crise est également dans la gestion de
projets de grande ampleur et de grande
complexité
il faut avoir en tête que concevoir une
telle infrastructure opérationnelle dans
des délais aussi courts
c'est c'est un enjeu auquel une
administration dea confronté que de
manière très épisodique et j'ai envie de
dire heureusement
or c'est une typologie de projets que
nous conduisons régulièrement juste pour
vous donner une idée sur les six
dernières années nous sommes intervenus
dans la reconfiguration de quelque chose
comme 700 chaîne logistique mondiale et
donc c'est cette expertise la voilà qui
nous a permis de leur donner moi de vous
interrompre l'instant mais ça s'est
justifié par le fait qu'il y avait
beaucoup de lieux de distribution
d'acteurs variés pour effectuer la
vaccination
mais ce choix et c'est un choix qui a
été fait de ce type de distribution de
vaccins on a vécu une autre situation
2009-2010 sous le nom de l'épisode 2 de
grippe h1n1 ont chois avait été
radicalement différent est entièrement
gérée par l'administration de ce pays de
faire de ce qu'on appelait des
vaccinodromes entre guillemets donc
est-ce que vous avez participé à la
décision enfin en tout cas pas par votre
expertise par des éléments que vous
auriez amené à l'administration pour
faire ce choix de ne pas reproduire le
schéma vaccinodromes de la grippe h1n1
pour un choix de diffusion beaucoup plus
complexe à gérer
merci monsieur le président alors pour
être vraiment très clair là dessus parce
que beaucoup de choses ont été dus nous
n'aurons été dit nous n'avons pas eu de
rôle dans la définition de la stratégie
vaccinale en tant que tel notre rôle a
été dans l'opérationnalisation des choix
dans la logistique finalement revenue
dans l'opérationnalisation de tous les
toutes les décisions et toutes les
actions qui ont suivi ces choix là et
donc les choix tels que qui vacciner
dans quel ordre quels vaccins utilisés
quels devraient être les lieux de
vaccination quel effecteur devait être
mobilisé dans ces voix là les décisions
sur le pass vaccinale les actions de
communication
tous ces éléments là étaient exclus de
notre périmètre d'intervention donc ça
c'est vraiment important de
le préciser
et du coup ce que ce que nous avons fait
très concrètement c'est d'appuyer
d'appuyer la taskforce interministériel
sur trois trois volets 1 le cadrage
opérationnelle et la mise à l'échelle de
ces flux logistiques et donc ça ça a été
un appui à la mise en oeuvre de pilotes
puis de test à l'échelle plus des
différents schémas logistiques
voilà et puis ensuite la construction
d'outils de pilotage qui permettent un
ajustement en continu de manière à
s'assurer que la qualité de service soit
au rendez-vous et qu'elles suivent
l'évolution l'évolution de la campagne
à titre d'exemple un des enjeux qu'on a
eu en préparation de l'été c'était
d'anticiper les flux et les déplacements
de la population pendant les périodes de
vacances pour nous assurer que les
vaccins soient là où se trouve la
demande
pendant pendant l'été donc on a eu tout
au long de la campagne des séries 2
voilà deux sujets très opérationnelle à
gérer donc ça c'est le premier élément
sur le pilotage des flux ensuite nous
sommes mobilisés pour mettre en place et
accompagner les processus et les outils
de coordination de la campagne est donc
au départ de définir et donc là vraiment
dans une logique de gestion de projet de
définir les rôles et responsabilités
afin ce que les centaines d'actions qui
devait être mené en parallèle le soin
et soit instruite comme il se devait et
puis ensuite la mise en place du
processus de suivi de manière à ce qu'on
puisse identifier très tôt ou est ce
qu'il y avait éventuellement des
déviations et des mesures correctives
correctives à apporter et puis dernier
point sur le match parking est donc une
cartographie on ait un suivi en continu
de l'avancement des campagnes de
vaccination dans d'autres pays à la fois
pour éclairer les choix qu'ils avaient
été pris et puis pour comparer
l'avancement de la campagne française à
ce qui se passait à l'international
la crise sanitaire vous avez également
une mission en janvier 2021 pour la mine
l'aide à la mise en place d'une tour de
contrôle stratégique auprès de santé
publique france accessoirement pour un
montant de 650 à 1000 euros d'après les
informations que nous avons recueillies
vous avez participé à la mise en place à
l'animation de brief quotidien
transverses interne à santé publique
france 2 fois par jour à 9 heures et à
15 heures est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer en quoi consistaient
concrètement cette mission s'il vous
plaît bien sûr et search monsieur le
président en a assez vite en fait dès
les premières semaines de la campagne il
est apparu que santé publique france
avait un rôle absolument central et
qu'un grand nombre des actions et des
activités tombait sous la responsabilité
et tout ça avec encore une fois des
enjeux de délai
qui se mesuraient en heure plus tôt
quand
en jours en semaines et dans un contexte
de tensions fortes sur les ressources de
spf tout simplement du fait de la grande
quantité d'activités qui étaient à gérer
en parallèle dans des délais extrêmement
courts et donc c'est le ministère qui
nous a demandé ouais je pense que madame
chaîne l'avait précisé lors de son
audition qui nous a demandé de venir
mobiliser un appui complémentaire auprès
du spf
pour effectivement appuyé ces travaux de
coordination extraordinairement intense
et j'insiste sur le côté absolument
exceptionnel de la situation
et donc il s'agissait de conduire des
revues on a conquis ont été appelés des
revues d'anticipation
est donc là plusieurs fois par semaine
c'était un travail pour anticiper
identifié anticiper les problématiques
ou les sujets qu'ils pouvaient engendrer
des risques opérationnels sur sur les
activités de spf et le schéma est donc
quelques exemples c'est comment est-ce
qu'on s'assure d'anticiper la montée des
cadences de livraison sur les capacités
de stockage à -80 et à moins 20 sur la
capacité de transport et la nature des
transports nécessaires sur la capacité
des établissements pivot qui ont un joué
un rôle clé dans un certain nombre des
flux logistiques enfin là et donc donc
s'assurer que à chaque fois qu'une
décision était prise au niveau
ministériel on prenait en compte toutes
les implications potentielles qui
risquait de poser poser des difficultés
ce tour de contrôle stratégie en fait
c'est une déclinaison de questions
logistiques que vous avez que vous aviez
alors la tour de contrôle qui a été mise
en place effectivement au sein du spf
était une tour de contrôle en tout cas
c'est le terme qui avait été retenu
spécifiquement pour suivre aiguille est
tous les aspects logistiques donc il
s'agissait bien de quelque chose de très
opérationnelle
de manière à coordonner encore une fois
l'ensemble des actions
qui était de tickets des encours et donc
on parle au fond
d'une fonction de gestion de projet et
voilà et et là encore pour vous donner
quelques exemples du type de sujets sur
lesquels cette tour de contrôle
permettait de s'assurer que encore une
fois les problématiques était anticipée
et puis tous les aléas
qui se produit a été gérée dans des
délais qui permettait d'assurer la bonne
qualité de service
c'était sur les flux amont donc dans
l'approvisionnement des dispositifs
médicaux notamment de pouvoir réagir si
un avion était bloqué si un fournisseur
avait un retard dans les livraisons
comment est ce qu'on anticipait ont géré
cette situation comment est ce que dans
les flux aval
on traitait les aléas dans les
livraisons dans les excursions de
température éventuellement donc c'est
tour de contrôle elle était là pour
s'assurer de la coordination et de la
gestion encore une fois dans des délais
extrêmement courts avec des engagements
de des enjeux de qualité de service
important
pour faire en sorte que que le résultat
soit soit au rendez vous et à côté de
cette mission qui sont qu'un de vos
collaborateurs a été mis à disposition
de spf et du ministère de la santé pour
assurer la coordination opérationnelle
sur le volet logistique
approvisionnement distribution des
vaccins ce qui a l'air d'être un peu le
sujet que vous venez d'évoquer pour la
tour de contrôle est cette personne
qualifié d'agent de liaison a fait
l'objet d'une facturation pour cent
soixante dix mille euros lors comment
est-ce que ça s'articule avec le marché
précédent oui et en fait l'articulation
c'est fait c'est fait dans le temps dans
un premier temps effectivement le
ministère nous a demandé de venir
appuyer cette coordination
extraordinairement intense à partir de
la mi-décembre et c'est cette
fonction-là qui a été appelé
agent de liaison et donc ça c'était
vraiment de s'assurer que
ce que je parlais ce dont je parlais
tout à l'heure sur l'anticipation et sur
la coordination d'actions qui étaient
prises au sein du ministère des ae res
de santé plus vite france et et de voilà
de s'assurer que cette coordination là
soient bien en place dans un deuxième
temps à partir de janvier excusez moi
monsieur vous ne pensez pas qu'il y a un
au sein de notre administration et
particulièrement de notre haute
administration des fonctionnaires qui
pourraient remplir ses missions et
notamment celle d'agent de liaison ça me
paraît quand même assez
étonnant on puisse faire appel à un
cabinet conseil pour faire la liaison
montre de jeu merci madame la
rapporteure je mange je m'attarderai pas
sur le terme d' agent de liaison qui
voilà qui tombe qu'on peut ré interroger
mais encore une fois c'est
nécessaire et de coordonner à des miles
à l'heure
près une série d'activités très complexe
en parallèle
à nécessiter encore une fois en
complément toutes les ressources qui
étaient déjà mobilisés et encore une
fois dans un contexte de tension sur les
ressources
de permettre de délivrer la qualité de
service
la rapporteure pour projet complété ce
point la réponse est oui mais pour voir
un plan contexte c'est que nous avons
été appelés tout début décembre il
fallait réagir très vite nous avons fait
ce rôle de manière temporaire ensuite
nous notre rôle a été ensuite de faire
monter une équipe dédiée qui a repris
l'ensemble de ces tâches et nous nous
sommes désengagés
si malheureusement la crise devait
s'amplifier
nous ne l'espérons pas bien évidemment
chacune et chacun
il n'y aurait toujours pas au sein de
l'administration des personnels pour
assumer ses missions
madame le rapporteur là nous notre vie
mais c'est une grande question que ben
oui mais moi je vais vous dire aussi
notre rôle c'est on a été appelé début
décembre il a fallu mobiliser pendant
l'ensemble des vacances de noël une
équipe d'une vingtaine de personnes pour
permettre au lancement mais c'est ça le
prend ensuite nous et nous le disons
c'est pas notre rôle et je les dis dans
mon propos liminaire d'exercer de
manière durable ses missions donc notre
hall a été ensuite de faire monter de
construire une équipe qui ensuite au
père est très dans la durée et pour
répondre à votre question oui madame il
faut que la santé la capacité à déployer
des équipes pour faire face à ça je
voudrais revenir sur sur les
explications données par monsieur mon
nom sur ces deux missions là je vais
très très simplement c'est de reformuler
pour mettre à l'épreuve ce que j'ai
compris de ce que vous avez voulu dire
via une première mission qui est en
quelque sorte une préfiguration
et elle s'avère insuffisante en
dimensionnement et on enchaîne on
continue avec chose d'un peu plus
robustes tels que la tour de contrôle
c'est à peu près ça sous votre contrôle
mais à ce moment là il faut m'expliquer
comment tout ça est compatible avec le
système de tourniquet dont on parlait
tout à l'heure si vous êtes un cap les
successivement deux fois pour des
missions alors que j'avais compris moins
que dans le cadre de l'accord cadre sa
tournée le principe du tourniquet
monsieur le président c'est que quand il
ya une continuité de projet
le cabinet demeure parce que il faut
aussi vis-à-vis de l'administration ne
pas faire de rupture de charge je pense
que ça aurait été assez inexplicable au
milieu de la crise donc césarine
transition un peu s'entendre et c'est un
tourniquet
ce qui est prévu au mettrais un peu
variable en fonction de ce que vous
mangez présidence est prévu dans le
texte qui définit cas les charges c'est
que lorsque le principe de continuité
justifie maintien du titulaire il
demeure c'est prévu j'ai encore une
question avant qu'on reprenne les
questions nos collègues sur cette
question sanitaire
je voulais savoir si vos consultants ont
eu physiquement accès à la cellule
interministérielle de crise si c'est le
cas c'est ce qu'il y avait des
procédures de sécurité de vérification
qui ont été prévues au préalable ce que
d'après les informations que nous avons
recueillies vous avez par exemple
appuyer la taxe corde dans la synthèse
et la préparation de réunions de comités
claeys qui fut posée donc cette présence
ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
précisions sur ces points
merci monsieur le président donc le
travail de l'équipe s'est faite au sein
du crdm où étaient basés ou est toujours
basée la cellule la cellule à la task
force un termite d'israël de gestion de
la crise et donc c'est là que l'équipe
l'équipe a joué son rôle
voilà avec après un accès aux salles de
réunion lorsqu'il y avait des réunions
mais c'est au sein du crdm et là où se
situe la taskforce interministériel nous
avons et ensuite
pour compléter la réponse est oui vous
avez eu accès et le deuxième partie de
la question c'est est ce qu'il y avait
des procédures particulières de sécurité
donc l'ensemble chacun des chacun des
consultants qui a été mobilisé a
rempli une déclaration d'intérêt
préalablement aux travaux et puis et
puis ensuite
[Musique]
l'accès au crd m
et protégés par des bâches donc l'équipe
a eu lieu au même titre que les agents
qui travaillent un badge
voilà
quelque chose pour préciser parce que le
crdm c'est le centre de réponse des
sites own au niveau du ministère de la
santé je sais pas si c'est à ça que vous
faites référence monsieur le président
mais nous nous avons toujours travaillé
dans les locaux de mission de la santé
ils ne vont pas eu accès d si vous
voulez faire référence à des centres de
réponse de crise
vous avez participé au conseil de
défense jamais non jamais là dessus il
faut être très clair notre rôle a été
d'aider des équipes de testeurs
vaccinale qui sont basés au sein du
ministère de la santé donc nos équipes
étaient basés là aux côtés des équipes
des métiers de la santé il travaillait
avec un badge et les questions de
sécurité applicables à l'ensemble des
salariés
et une dernière question sur la qualité
à ce que vous êtes encore sur des
missions liées à la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui
donc fin décembre le ministère nous a
nous a sollicités pour pour venir
apporter un appui complémentaire
de manière ponctuelle à la tasse force
dans le contexte de l'augmentation de la
pression épidémique et du rebond et pour
pour un appui très ponctuelles dans
l'accélération de la campagne de rappel
de manière à faire en sorte que chaque
français aient pu bénéficier d'un
créneau de rappel avant la fin janvier
donc on intervient maintenant mais
encore une fois de manière très
ponctuelle en appelons donc la fin de
l'illusion l'émission de la ferme
l'émission de l'agent de liaison sont
terminées les missions de la koala ont
appuyé là
et assume cette responsabilité doit
absolument et peut-être j'en profite
pour préciser que
systématiquement
nous avons travaillé à développer les
compétences des équipes au fur et à
mesure qu'elles se sont constitués
étoffé et 2 et 2 et d'assurer le transit
de transfert de tous les outils modèle
et c'est qu'on a construit
aux équipes de la tasse forces et vos
équipes de spa donc il ya eu aussi ce
souci de faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des activités soient repris à leur
compte par par les agents publics
merci stéphane sauterelle maintenant oui
merci monsieur le président j'avais
j'avais une question tu peux plus large
sur le modèle économique en fait puisque
vous nous avez dit si j'ai bien entendu
que le pôle public représente à peu près
5% de l'activité
du cabinet et que vous aviez des prix
qui était de 15 à 20% inférieur alors ce
que vous interveniez sur le prix public
pardon par rapport au secteur privé par
ailleurs mais vous êtes largement revenu
depuis sur le peler les pro bono qui
sont dans des interventions gracieuse et
vous avez présenté comme répondant à
l'impact social ou sociétal que votre
société
poursuit simplement vous avez cité
quelques exemples types tibio sur
lesquels je m'interroge parce que ça
pourrait être effectivement un marché
intéressant important or vous avez dit
que vous n'aviez pas de missions
marchande après des interventions pro
bono du coup ma question elle est sûre
le le modèle économique qui est qui est
le vôtre pour
engager des moyens pour 5% de l'activité
à un prix inférieur aux autres
interventions de plus avec une matrice
des risques peut-être aussi qui
accroît je dirais le banc pour la
société de cette intervention donc
j'aurais aimé que vous nous éclairer sur
ce point la remercie
[Musique]
une question très juste je reviens à ma
condition que nous avons pas fait de
projet pour les gigots payant à la suite
de cette mission juste aussi pour
clarifier les missions qui étaient au
moment du dépôt de la candidature
donc c'est aussi très en amont de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui
je reviens sur effectivement cette
problématique de pourquoi souhaitons
agir pense que le secteur économique le
public pendant un enjeu fondamental de
notre économie nous estimons nous en
tant que quantité que c'est important
d'accompagner que les responsables
publics de ce secteur dans la réussite
de projets qui sont majeurs a par
exemple de la vaccination pour
l'ensemble du bien-être collectif et
l'ensemble du secteur donc ça a été un
choix fait collectivement par le bureau
de paris d'accepter des conditions
économiques dégradées pour pouvoir y
opérer ceci étant dit je pense
qu'effectivement et le président du
syntec a fait référence semble de
cabinet aujourd'hui n'y sont pas
présents je pense que c'est aussi
important du point de vue du secteur
public d'assurer des conditions qui
permettent d'avoir à sam de partenaires
engagés dans la durée dans des
conditions économiques via pour les
accompagner sur ce sujet
on va prendre encore des questions nous
collègues et puis on viendra le voir
porter donc laurent burgoa
merci monsieur le président madame le
rapporteur messieurs les directeurs
j'aimerais revenir monsieur directeur ta
déchets sur une question que vous posez
notre président
c'était par rapport donc lorsque
certains de vos salariés pourraient
avoir un conflit d'intérêt entre
activités professionnelles et activités
on va dire extra professionnelles
associatives voix
politiques vous nous avez répondu à
notre président que vous contrôlez je
vous remercie de votre réponse mais
j'aimerais approfondir sait de quelle
manière
précise et si par exemple vous avez une
preuve écrite ce contre la hesse que
pour elle à fournir leur commission
denquête je remercie
l'écouté
oui je pense qu'on verra vous sur ce
point mais les engagements qui indiquait
font partie du code de conduite qui sont
signés par l'ensemble de nos salariés
et nous mettons en place qui piquent
mans là en préparation de la campagne
nous avons réexprimer les principes très
nette qui encadre la participation à des
campagnes et nous les suivons jeu le
sénateur
je ne sais pas si là c'est la réponse
satisfait le sénateur benoit
la question des très concrètement est-ce
que vous avez les moyens de suivre le
temps de le temps des présences de vos
salariés le temps qui est dû à votre
société par rapport à ce qui peut être
fournir pratt l'une - yvan ah oui nous
avons un système de suivi effectivement
fin il le dit 2 alors j'ai utilisé
seulement essayé de l'éviter des terme
de jargon mais de staffing ce n'est que
quand un consultant et est affecté à un
projet en fait il est marqué dans nos
bases comme affecté à un projet donc
effectivement tracé le fait que des
consultants
quelles missions il était affecté à un
moment donné et donc ça c'est
effectivement auditables dans nos
ballons au fait on s'attend pas à ce que
vous fassiez pointé des salariés de ce
niveau là on va être très clair mais ce
que vous nous dites quand même c'est que
à travers les quantités de travail
affecté à vos salariés
il rendu donc que vous avez vous avez
grosso modo le contrôle de du fait
qu'ils ont bien effectuer les missions
pour lesquelles ils sont payés par
mckinsey et exactement c'est à dire que
moi je sais que tous nos consultants un
autre nom de données sont affectés à une
tâche donc je sais qu'il est à lui et à
cette tâche
ensuite ce que je ne sais pas vous dire
monsieur sénateurs c'est que s'il
utilise son téléphone personnel pendant
les horaires de travail pour faire des
missions associatif ou collectifs ça je
peux pas le tracé c'est ça votre prends
et je pense pas que ce soit souhaitable
mais en tout cas je jugeais
hockey
sénateur patrice joly maintenant et puis
nathalie goulet pour en complément on
reviendra à madame la rapporte merci
monsieur le président merci messieurs je
voudrais savoir sur le pour le comité
d'action publique monsieur thomas landon
a été membre de ce comité et je
regardais un peu les critiques a pu
avoir par rapport aux provisions
convaincant et émilie st par ce comité
en matière de transformation public
c'est qu'il y avait d'abord une vision
essentiellement budgétaire des missions
de service public et à partir de là je
voudrais vous poser la question suivante
sachant que les la neutralité
intellectuelle n'existe pas même si
l'honnêteté et la rigueur intellectuelle
peuvent se cultive et bien évidemment
sur la conception de la et la vision de
la société j'aimerais savoir comment
vous positionner le cabinet mckinsey sur
le plan idéologique et philosophiques
sachant au surplus les liens
institutionnels ou personnelles à
travers les membres de mckinsey
attendant bien par rapport à certains
clubs de réflexion n'a évoqué la succube
montagne tout à l'heure il ya aussi le
temps que également le think tank entre
temps
dont le positionnement
intellectuelle et idéologique et est
clairement déterminée merci
monsieur le sénateur je ferai une
première réponse générale et ensuite
monsieur thomas london répondra plus
physiquement sur chaque à 22 je pense
que la question de vous poser est très
fondé c'est à dire de savoir un peu la
note la neutralité de notre posture est
également les éléments et éventuellement
d'idéologie implicite qu'on peut
embarquer à travers nos travaux une
recommandation et je pense que c'est un
point qui est important parce qu'il faut
signe qu'en permanence on s'interroge
sur ce qu'on peut embarquer notamment de
manière implicite et à ce titre fou que
des travaux sociologiques comme ceux de
philippe bizet sur la réforme de l'état
ou de travaux récents sur new policy
management sont une sorte de réflexion
très importante pour nous
il faut penser qu'à 4 points moi qui
sont importants en tout cas clarifier il
est dit en introduction
il ya souvent cette critique dans la new
policy management qui recourent
plusieurs critiques nous notre point et
de ne jamais considérer le secteur
public comme une entreprise privée le
dis clairement et pouvoir croire qu'on
peut transposer des des solutions
applicables au secteur public ceci étant
dit quand on regarde des processus
métier il ya un certain nombre de
processus qu'on peut retrouver dans
certaines industries je prends un
exemple de celui dans le traitement des
dossiers une grande partie de s'assurer
de la contre étude des dossiers des
différentes étapes ce sont des types de
processus qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
secteurs dans la suivante secteur
bancaire et donc à ce titre aussi
intéressant de réfléchir sur quelles
peuvent être les enseignements au niveau
des processus métier qui peut être
pertinent pour des décideurs publics
dans les annonces de manière contexte
réaliser je pense de deuxième élément un
peu de de vue sur les cas il faut deux
présents ne pensons pas non plus qu'on
peut transposer des solutions d'autres
pays au contexte national français c'est
à dire que le contexte est dans le fruit
d' histoire longue pour ça que nous
avons fait le choix de créer à plus de
15 ans dans le secteur public en france
pour pouvoir s'en créé auprès de ses
clients si étendue là aussi il y à
l'administration française triangle
qualité il ya d'autres administrations
de grande qualité qui sont confrontés à
peu près au même type de problématique
est donc c'est vrai que le pouvoir
apporter à des responsables
opérationnels métiers les solutions
qu'on peut trouver par d'autres pour
répondre aux mêmes défis et je pense une
source de valeur pour les décideurs
publics mais là encore en et filtrant et
on ne transposant pas des solutions qui
correspondent pas au contexte
institutionnel politique et social
français
le troisième point vous l'avez mentionné
si cette critique éventuellement de voir
la politique publique sous le prisme
uniquement du budgétaire et l'a
pareillement ne se feront pas donc c'est
là que la finalité de la politique
publique c'est d'améliorer l'expérience
une citoyens et du coup nous prenons à
chaque fois une réflexion autour de
l'amélioration toute cette dimension là
et sur cette vallée cet aspect coup ce
qu'on trouve important comme mesure
c'est pas le coup en tant que tel mais
l'impact le rendement économique et
social de l'euro investi collectivement
et ses analyses là qu'on est en place et
dernier point il ya souvent aussi autour
de cette critique de ce que des méthodes
qu'on pourrait faire peur un point
autour de l'obsession des indicateurs
alors peut-être que cette critique j'ai
souscrit un peu un peu plus c'est vrai
que nous notre rôle est pas de prendre
des postures mais d'essayer d'apporter d
analyse factuelle pour éclairer la prise
de décision donc oui nous essayons en
amont d'éclairer les différentes options
de quantifier les scénarios les impacts
et en aval nous sommes également
important toujours d'être en mesure de
pouvoir construire des indicateurs qui
permettent de mesurer dans la durée
l'expérience client et l'efficacité du
processus pour que les responsables
publics puissent les piloter mais pour
revenir sur votre point elle va laisser
de mal on donne respectifs je pense que
ce débat vous remettre en question aussi
les éléments d'idéologie implicite
embarqué est fondamentale
et pour compléter très simplement sur
sur cap cap 2022 on a répondu à une
sollicitation de l'exécutif en
l'occurrence j'ai répondu à titre
personnel à une seule utilisation de
l'exécutif pour se mouiller dans un
travail qui a été un travail là encore
collectif qui a mobilisé une quarantaine
d'experts
qui était issu et donc j'ai contribué
aux travaux sur la santé du monde
associatif dense est donc passé le cadre
de cette intervention
l'aigle et l'examen marché enfin c'était
un marché non ce n'était pas un marché
non c'était une sollicitation de
l'exécutif
cette prestation gratuite à titre
individuel de thomas london voilà pour
contribuer à des travaux à des travaux
collectifs aux côtés de fonctionnaires
aux côtés de professionnels de santé de
personnes issues du monde associatif et
donc voilà on a on on a mené des travaux
collectifs sur le domaine de la santé
qui ont amené un certain nombre de
propositions qui
visait
encore une fois pas juste
l'efficience économique mais qui visait
une amélioration des conditions d'accès
de prise en charge des patients en train
notamment sur la dépendance par exemple
d'amélioration des conditions d'exercice
des professionnels et de d'efficacité de
la défense
celui d'activités bénévoles
oui
on a pas une mobilisation des équipes
nathalie goulet pour une question je
l'espère assez rapide parce qu'on a
encore pas mal d'autres castings 1
secondes pour compléter ce qu'a dit mon
collègue était lorsque par exemple vous
avez un registre pour noter les
interventions extérieures non
professionnels ce qui permettrait de
contrôler et éventuellement les conflits
d'intérêts ça ce serait assez simple la
deuxième chose c'est que vous êtes
intervenu très longtemps enfin à de très
nombreuses reprises pendant la crise est
ce que vous pourriez peut-être sous
réserve de ce que va dire madame le
rapporteur mais nous procurer un schéma
dans le dans le temps des dates de vos
interventions et de la nature des
missions parce que ça permettrait de
mieux comprendre à quel stade vous êtes
intervenu et pourquoi parce que comme
vous êtes intervenu sur plusieurs
missions de façon successive
ce serait peut-être bien d'avoir ce
schéma là dans le dans le temps pour
qu'on puisse muffat que moi à titre
personnel dans tous les cas peut-être
les autres aussi puissent mieux
comprendre la nature de vos
interventions
sur ce deuxième point même stinat triste
bien sûr sur le premier point la loi
n'autorise pas moi en tant qu'employeur
a demandé à mes salariés s'ils ont des
activités politiques syndicales ou
associatives donc
donc je suis pas en état de pouvoir
faire ce que vous souhaitez madame la
sénatrice
le pardon je vais être très clair avec
nos collègues donc madame d'un
rapporteur ou encore une existence 8e
monsieur montaugé puis madame boyer il
même la varde pour qu'on va essayer de
faire tout ça en dix minutes chacun va y
met du sien merci alors d'abord deux
petit retour en arrière si vous
permettez sur la campagne de rappel en
décembre pouvez vous nous donner le
montant
de cette mission n'est pas deuxième
petit complément monsieur takieddine
pardon excusez moi d'après les macronix
vous auriez utiliser votre mail mckinsey
pour échanger avec l'équipe de campagne
cela ne paraît qu'il pas compatibles ne
paraît pas compatible pardon avec les
rec vous évoquez est ce que vous
pourriez me dire si c'est avéré ou pas
et enfin ma question c'est en 2019 vous
avez obtenu une prestation pour mckinsey
a obtenu une prestation pour la cnav
précisément intitulé appui à la cnav
pour la préparation à une potentielle
réforme des retraites pour un montant
quand même de près de neuf cent vingt
mille euros est ce que vous pourriez
nous dire quelles étaient précisément le
rôle de mckinsey s'il vous plaît
donc pour ce qui est de la plus
complémentaire nous vous fournirons par
retour les éléments bien sûr et pour ce
qui est de l'accompagnement à la cnav
effectivement en 2019 donc il s'est agit
donc la perspective de la réforme des
retraites était là et donc il s'est agit
de réfléchir aux axes de d'évolution de
l'organisation de la cnav pour faire en
sorte qu'ils assument mieux leur mission
et à la fois dans au fond dans la
perspective de de la réforme éventuelle
mais j'irai de manière plus générale
comment est ce que on améliore le
fonctionnement des fonctions métier
l'appui etc ça a été une mission qui a
permis aussi de dégager un certain
nombre d'axés d'amélioration dans
l'organisation au delà de la préparation
là d'une réforme
cette question si fillon une erreur
d'usagé professionnel
c'était une erreur utiliser l'image qu'a
donnée due à une suite interne
messieurs président je vais mais aussi
peut-être parler des bonnets jeu
s'explique figurez vous que je n'ai pas
oublié le sujet simplement je peux que
j'essaie de donner satisfaction à mes
collègues donc ce que je propose c'est
qu'on va prendre les trois questions à
la suite là il ya des recoupements ça
vous pouvez traiter tout d'un coup et
ensuite je vais revenir sur les données
parce que j'ai bien noté votre propos
introductif mais j'ai mes questions qui
sont prêtes rassurez vous alors tout
d'abord monsieur montaugé merci monsieur
le président il a pu arriver dans une
période récente que des conseillers de
cabinets ministériels ancien consultants
de mckinsey france contribue à la
définition et la mise en oeuvre de
politiques de santé publique pour
lesquelles vous avez fait des
préconisations dans le cadre de marchés
en bonne et due forme cette situation
est-elle selon vous de nature à
développer des politiques publiques plus
pertinente pour le citoyen français qui
au final année le destinataire je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup valérie boyer
merci monsieur le président mais une
partie des la question de vous les posez
a déjà été posée moi j'aurais bien aimé
dans les réponses que vous aurez pu
faire messieurs
avoir un focus particulier sur les liens
que vous avez eue pendant vos missions
pro bono ou les autres avec pour la
santé notamment avec les ars parce que
effectivement
on ne cesse de poser la question de de
l'organisation de l'administration avec
des fonctionnaires extrêmement qualifiés
est particulièrement compétent sur le
sujet et du rôle en plus des cabinets
conseils en quoi effectivement comme
nous ont posé mes collègues à plusieurs
reprises dans cette audition et dans les
autres auditions l'âme l'émission que
vous remplissez ne n'aurais pas pu être
remplies par l'administration qui existe
déjà et notamment pour une
administration de mission certes mais
particulièrement pointu sur la question
de l'organisation de la santé puisque
c'est l'origine de sa création et c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'aurais bien
aimé savoir quels étaient les liens
particuliers que vous avez pu
s'entretenir notamment avec cette partie
de l'organisation de la santé à savoir
que sont les ars je vous remercie et
pareil pour la ds est ailleurs merci
christine demande
si je voudrais revenir sur la
participation de monsieur londons aux
travaux de cap 2022 que je sais pas vous
votre visage vous revenez pas je suis
allé vérifier la composition de ce
comité dont j'étais membre est
effectivement vous n'apparaissez pas
dans la liste des membres intronisés par
le premier ministre donc j'aurais
vraiment voulu savoir à quel titre vous
aviez participé parce que tout cas dans
le groupe pour lequel j'ai travaillé
seuls les membres qui avaient été
désignés ont ensuite mené des auditions
et nous avons passé de commande c'est à
dire que les gens venaient répondait à
nos questions mais il n'y avait pas deux
de travail par la suite et en tant que
tel il n'avait pas voix pour ensuite
participer aux travaux d'écriture dont
je vous accorde qu'ils ont largement
échappé aux travaux aux membres de
ladite commission donc est ce à dire que
vous avez pris la plume pour venir vous
substituer à notre ce qui aurait dû être
notre travail enfin voilà ça serait même
nous exprimer sur ce point question bien
précise donc que messieurs on va
reprendre les choses chronologiquement
si vous voulez bien parce que les
finalement les questions sont assez
différentes d'abord lesquels la question
du sénateur monte au jeu s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le président donc sur ce
premier point je pense vous faites
référence à une à ce qui a pu être dit
lors d'une audition précédente où il
aurait été dit que on est on il ya eu un
collaborateur de chez nous qui a
travaillé chez nous pour aller ensuite
au cabinet du ministre de la santé c'est
tout simplement une information qui est
fausse
la personne en question a travaillé au
ministère de la santé et ne nous a
rejoints que après elle a été chez nous
entre 2011 et 2020 et donc le fait de
dire qu' il ya eu un aller-retour est
simplement une information qui est
fausse
sur la sur la deuxième question
concernant les ars
nous n'avons pas eu l'occasion de
mémoire d'intervenir
en appui je dirais
direct dares dans le cadre de nos
activités on a travaillé au ministère on
a on a eu l'occasion d'intervenir dans
des hôpitaux mais jamais directement
auprès des ars après évidemment si je
reprends l'exemple de la campagne de
vaccination
les ars ont un rôle absolument central
dans la mise en oeuvre à l'échelon
régional
de toutes les nombreuses activités que
j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure et donc
beaucoup de notre appui auprès de la
task force interministérielle a été pour
aider à structurer et voilà et améliorer
la relation et les que le contact et le
travail avec avec les ars et enfin sur
le dernier point de câbles 2022 donc
encore une fois j'ai été appelé
alors j'ai été appelé pas au moment de
la constitution de la commission au
départ donc c'est pour ça que je ne
figure pas sur la liste initiale à
l'ouverture mais j'ai été mobilisé par
l'exécutif en cours de travaux deux ou
trois semaines après et donc si vous
regardez le rapport etc voilà je fais
partie des membres de cette commission
simplement j'étais morizet en qualité
d'expert de trois semaines après le
démarrage est donc j'ai voyagé
j'ai vécu la même chose que vous avez
vécu
merci pour ces précisions alors comme je
partage la grande appétence de monsieur
tadjeddine pour la question des données
on va y venir maintenant s'octroie
d'ailleurs quelques instants
supplémentaires sur la durée prévue mais
je pense que ça ne nécessite
donc ces fameuses donner c'est de la
connaissance que vous accumulez lors de
vos travaux au profit du secteur public
est ce qu'elles sont mobilisés ces
données pour d'autres prestations dans
le cadre de ces benchmarks vous avez
commencé à donner des éléments
d'explication propos liminaire mais ça
mérite qu'on y revienne je voulais
savoir en particulier si les données de
vos clients sont détruites à l'issue de
vos prestations ou seulement anonymisées
et qu'une fois anonymisées elles peuvent
servir des benchmark c'est pas ça que je
vous ai entendu défendre tout à l'heure
comme modèle vous avez peut-être est-ce
que ça vaut le coup quand même de
repréciser les choses ensuite toujours
dans cet ordre
deux questions de la donner l'adn de la
dr 2 e s vous a par exemple commander
une ont eu en janvier 2021 une étude d'à
peu près cinq cent mille euros sur
l'utilisation des données dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire en lien
avec la stratégie nationale de santé
2018 2022 quel a été le traitement de
ces données sensibles de façon très
concrète et puis enfin votre société
mckinsey france est elle soumise au
cloud act américain c'est à dire pour
ceux qui l'ignoraient je pense qu'il y
en a pas dans la salle mais la capacité
pour le gouvernent le juge américain de
d'avoir accès à l'ensemble de ces
données
je suis président et découvrirez
peut-être cesser ces trois sous
questions sur la question de la donner
je pense que le premier point c'est en
de rappeler que pour nous la donnait
vraiment au coeur la relation de
confiance qu'on a avec nos clients et on
effectue chaque année plusieurs milliers
de projets avec les clients des secteurs
privé et public depuis une cinquantaine
d'années s'il y avait le moindre doute
de la part de nos clients sur l' usage
qu'on ferait de leurs données
confidentielles
je pense que nous serions pas
aujourd'hui le partenaire de confiance
de nos clients alors par rapport à ces
données ya peut-être deux questions
simples et de questions plus complexes
une question première question simple
l'utilisation de ces données pour le
belge part indiqué dans mon propos
liminaires et j'expliquerai comme on le
fait de la réponse est non nous
n'utilisons pas les données
confidentielles ne vont pas accès même
après pour réaliser des travaux de
synthèse
deuxième question simple aussi sur la
question du patriot act et du cloud
actes il a été évoqué dans cette
commission que nos données seriez serait
pourrait être siphonné jeu reprend les
termes à travers le cloud est et patriot
act monsieur poupart l'a rappelé patates
et le cloud acte n'a pas été conçu pour
des sociétés comme nous il a été conçu
pour des sociétés qui gèrent et opère
des des données et ce même domaine du
cloud il ce n'est pas destiné pour des
entreprises comme nous
alors deux questions plus complexes là
dessus on s'arrête deux groupes bien sûr
c'est pas pour des sociétés comme vous
c'est à dire que dans la rédaction oui
la loi américaine ça ne permet pas ou je
ricane t il céder alors j'ai pas le
terme exact mais c'est précisément sur
tout ce qui est
jeu l'excellent texte mais oui c'est
écrit c'est pour des opérateurs du cloud
du stockage de l'hébergement et c'est
écrit comme ça dans les textes on
enregistre votre réponse merci donc ça
vous pouvez le vérifier et c'est ce que
aussi monsieur poupart a indiqué lors de
son audition enfin donc chasse la
réponse est claire alors il ya deux
questions qui sont plus complexes qui
est concrètement comment aussi fait
comment on fait comment nous nous y
prenons pour assurer la confidentialité
des données ces questions que vous posez
alors là dessus je vais décrire un peu
pour le rendre concret c'est vrai que la
manière dont on fonctionnait nous avons
mis en place des principes de
ségrégation des documents donc on
travaille sur une technologie qui
s'appelle box ou en fait les données
sont stockées et il ya un nombre limité
qui sont uniquement les personnes qui
peuvent avoir accès à ces données qui
ont accès à ces espaces de stockage
interne la liste des personnes qui ont
accès à ces données est validée en début
de projet avec le commanditaire et donc
typiquement uniquement l'équipe coeur
qu'à être habilité à accès à ces données
et nous nous pouvons suivre les traces
et il peut y avoir accès ou pas et
ensuite vous nous avez posé la question
les règles de stockage sont un peu
variable selon les contrats cadres dans
certains contrats cadres on nous demande
de détruire l'ensemble des données au
bout de deux trois ou cinq ans dans
d'autres cas on nous demande parfois
donc de conserver un copie des livrables
finale donc j'ai mis en place à travers
ces boîtes dans lequel l'ensemble des
données liées à un projet sont traités
et personne d'autre que les personnes
habilitées n'a accès à ces données la
deuxième question complexe c'est comment
nous et pouvons quelles sont les règles
nous mettons en place pour nous prémunir
contre un risque éventuel de piratage du
cyber attaques
là dessus nous essayons de mettre en
place les meilleures pratiques possibles
de protection de nos données à titre
d'exemple nous avons mis en place dans
les technologies que nous utilisions
comme box ou comme mme un double système
d'encryptage il ya quand plus de celui
qui est proposé nous avons rajouté un
nom propre qui est uniquement réservée à
nos clients et à nous nous faisons aussi
régulièrement des audits externes pour
s'assurer qu'on a le meilleur standard
ensuite l'appareil membres ces
pourparlers indiqué le risque zéro
n'existe pas mais nous faisons en sorte
de proposer à nos clients les meilleures
solutions je vous interrogez pas sur la
cyber sécurité surtout que vous devez
donner du conseil en cybersécurité donc
à moi on peut espérer en tout cas les
cabinets de conseil certains mouvements
peut espérer que vous soyez
particulièrement pointu sur le sujet
je voulais revenir sur
la notion de confiance que vous avez
mise en évidence et alors ça ça nous a
été aussi renvoyée assez régulièrement
par les administrations que vous avez
interrogé moi je le comprends comme
étant le fait d'une relation dans la
durée qui qui veut que si le mauvais
usage et effet de donner un jour ou
l'autre ça finit par se savoir et que en
plus les choses sont écrites dans les
marchés qui sont passés avec des
obligations etc mais tout ça a vraiment
du sens il ya des moyens de contrôles de
la part du client sur le devenir de ces
données est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
concrètement comment le client
l'administration qui vous a confié des
données peut vérifier que tout ce que
vous venez de nous décrire est
effectivement mis en oeuvre ou est-ce
que ils sont simplement obligé de vous
croire sur parole alors monsieur le
président je voudrais aussi faire
peut-être la distinction entre
différents types de données et là encore
je suis pas en charge pour notre cabinet
c'est des questions qui sont complexes
dans le pool de frais techniques et
juridiques et je vous donne ma
perception tant que responsable du pôle
secteur public il ya trois types de
données il ya les données de nature
personnelle ça nous ne souhaitons pas
les traiter c'est un encadrement très
spécifique ce n'est pas notre métier de
les traiter nous ne faisons pas il ya un
deuxième type de données qui sont
extrêmement sensibles
ces données là nous ne souhaitons pas
les héberger dans nos systèmes donc si
la situation se présente nous demandons
à travailler sur les ordinateurs de
clients pour que les données restent
hébergées chez lui
et ensuite il ya un troisième niveau qui
sont les données que nous avons
auxquelles nous avons accès dans le
cadre du projet
qu'ils essaient précédent les contrats
cadre que nous avons nous devons les
traiter comme les données
confidentielles donc vis-à-vis du client
nous présentons et nous expliquons au
début du projet les règles que nous
mettons que devenez-vous d'écrire sur
les usages du box nous listons avec lui
quelles sont les personnes qui ont accès
à ces boîtes nous précisons avec eux des
conditions de destruction d'utilisation
des données est ensuite 500 le
souhaitent bien on peut proposer des
audits pour qu'ils puissent vérifier que
les règles mises en place
merci et en l'occurrence là les données
de qui ont été utiles dans la gestion de
la crise sanitaire ces données est ont
été détruites les vous met alors en
l'occurrence il s'agissait pas pour nous
de récolter ces données la médée
comprendre auprès des acteurs quels
étaient les données qu'ils avaient eu à
leur disposition et quel usage il on
avait donc on a pas eu on n'a pas eu
accès à ces données c'est vrai sur
l'usagé qui en a été fait par les
acteurs
bien je crois qu'on est arrivé au terme
mais j'allais vous proposer à la
rapporteure la conclusion donc elle à la
question finale bienvenus alors pour
rire ou pas pouvez vous nous dire
pourquoi vous êtes surnommée la firme
jeu je pense que les débats qu'il ya
aujourd'hui montre en tout cas qui a
besoin d'être plus beaucoup plus
pédagogiques explicatif dans le type de
prestation que nous faisons auprès des
acteurs publics et qui gagne mais à très
concrète ce que nous faisons en ce que
nous faisons pas que nous serions
claquer la firme madame rapporteur
merci messieurs et donc nous attendons
les compléments que j'évoquais en début
de séance sur les demandes écrites que
nous avons formulées ici en cours
[Musique]